major headline here Babylon B Matt Walsh
jumps out of the bushes at Easter egg
hunt to inform the kids that bunnies
laying eggs is biologically impossible
who tells their kids that the Easter
Bunny lays the eggs is that what people
are being told so that's the only thing
that this story gets wrong is that I
wouldn't be going up to kids and say you
know Easter Bunny doesn't lay it doesn't
lay eggs because I never knew that
really that's what you're telling is
that what parents are telling kids that
the Easter Bunny actually lays the eggs
like a chicken as you know I'm a Santa
Claus apologist you know I I I'm fully
on board with the Santa Claus thing
Easter Bunny's always been a little too
weird a little too disturbing I didn't
know that that kids were also being told
that this mutant sorcerer east bunny
lays eggs I always when I was a kid I
always thought that the Easter Bunny he
has the eggs and it's like in a basket
and he hides them places